I'm patty Bedell  and I'm not your typical pageant queen  there are things about me that I wish  that I could change but I can't she's  sort of the most amazing girl I've ever  met  yeah sounds horrible you're a beauty  queen with a hot boyfriend it doesn't  matter what I look like my life is a  total mess I have a murder suspect okay  what yeah did you do it no of course I  didn't nothing can change who I am or  what I've done dad let the past drag you  down we're leaving all the drama behind  she's still my car she's been through a  lot I decided to take control of my life  if anything about death or destruction I  need to focus on my future and then who  knows what I could do  [Applause]  [Music]  you can get away oh that just never  really does get old  I know patty she's a lot of things but  she's not a killer  [Music]  Oh  get excited that was [ __ ] awesome  [Music]  you